article après article attali macias
consulte le code de justice
administrative
un outil de travail quotidien pour la
présidente du tribunal administratif de
versailles
on sait pas tout donc on a toujours
besoin de vérifier des questions de
compétence territoriale des questions
procédure à 55 ans elle vient de prendre
la tête de la juridiction administrative
à versailles une carrière de magistrate
qui se dessine après son bac littéraire
lorsqu'elle rentre à l'institut
politique de paris on se cultivait et
j'avais l'impression d'apprendre ce que
tout le monde a envie de savoir c'est à
dire le droit l'économie mais aussi la
vie politique
après sciences po nathalie macias
intègre l'école nationale de
l'administration à seulement 22 ans
promotion denis diderot
c'est une partie de la promo seul ans
que je suis là on était allé on avait
été reçue à la préfecture de la seine et
marne par le préfet de la seine et marne
de l'époque avec le directeur de l'école
qu'ils étaient simon aura des sons
d'entrée à l'ena elle est en stage
première expérience huit mois à la
préfecture de la nièvre le monde de
l'administration des préfectures le
monde de la province le fait de vivre
seul
ça c'était l'intérêt de la scolarité de
l'ena c'était les stages qui tout d'un
coup mettait la jeune étudiante que
j'étais en situation de travail
attiré par le contentieux administratif
nathalie masia s'oriente vers une
carrière dans la magistrature
administrative elle trouve sa vocation à
travers l'utilité publique
on est là à la fois pour
servir l'intérêt général et puis aussi
protéger les intérêts particuliers et
protégé l'administration contre elle
même hostile
sorti de l'ena elle est affectée au
tribunal administratif de lille elle a
occupé des postes de rapporteur public
et de président de chambre à paris melun
et nantes
elle devient chef de juridiction à
poitiers en 2012 avant de rejoindre en
septembre dernier
versailles sous son autorité 43
magistrats et 56 agents de greffe
mon travail est essentielle c'est un
travail d'encadrement et d'organisation
j'ai toujours une activité
juridictionnelle puisque je vais
présider chacune des chambres à tour de
rôle récemment deux affaires traitées
par le tribunal administratif de
versailles ont marqué la présidente
la requête a été déposée par salle
abdeslam qui est détenu à la maison
d'arrêt de fleury mérogis et qui
contestait sa mise sous vidéo
surveillance 24 heures sur 24
et puis nous avons eu aussi une affaire
très douloureuse qui est celle de
l'inhumation de abala qui est l'assassin
des deux policiers de magnanville au
mois de juin 2016 dossier après dossier
nathalie macias poursuit son activité au
service de la protection de
l'administration et des administrés